at tel aviv swarovski hospital the race
to vaccinate the population is in full
swing
it's about protection confidence getting
back to normal
of course but as israel leads the way
with its vaccine program
they are now able to build a vital
real-world picture
of just how effective the vaccine is
[Music]
the hospital director he's been the
government's chief coroner
and he's somewhat of a celebrity around
here
i believe truly believe this is the
beginning of the end because the vaccine
creates the immune response we see that
clearly
and we see a change in the people that
are
becoming severely ill with corona
and moderately in corona people that
have got the vaccine are more protected
until now we could only rely on the
clinical trials to determine efficacy
but now with a quarter of the population
here inoculated
and 75 of those over 60 the real results
of the fisa jab
are emerging professor ran balaser is
the data cruncher a physician
epidemiologist and chief innovation
officer at clelit
the country's largest healthcare
provider we compared
200 000 people above the age of 60 that
were vaccinated
we took a comparison group of 200 000
people same age not vaccinated that were
matched
to this group on various variables
and then we looked to see what is the
daily
positivity rate and we saw that there
was
no difference between vaccinated and
unvaccinated until day 14 post
vaccination
but on day 14 past vaccination a drop
of 33 in positivity was witnessed
in the vaccinated group and not
in the unvaccinated group it matches
pfizer's clinical trial data but does
raise real questions about the uk
strategy for delaying the second dose
the uk government paper justified the
second dose delay because they judged
that the fisa vaccine was 89
effective 14 days after the first dose
that's much more than the preliminary
israeli data suggests
the practice in israel is to provide the
second vaccine at three weeks
so we are following protocol would uh
the level of protection
um again in general and against specific
new strains going to be changed if one
is not taking that second dose
all of these are open-ended questions
and only time will tell
the analysis is preliminary but it's
based on real-world data
and here they say it suggests that the
uk efficacy estimate of 89 percent after
one dose of pfizer
is very optimistic mark stone sky news
in tel aviv